this is all Viviana Pereira has left of
her father memories a few letters and
photos does asaurus let's this is the
last photo that was taken of him I think
it was the day before it's also the
photo they used for the search of an
orgasm for my [ __ ] altec juan pereira
went missing in the Colombian city of
Vav senseo in april nineteen
ninety-eight a few months earlier
Viviana had seen her father for the last
time they're meeting in Berlin is burned
into her memory via NASA z1 lines
Christmas of 1997 was the last time I
saw him it was after new year when we
took him to the airport it was a really
strange goodbye it was like it was the
last time we were going to see each
other I'll remember that forever because
he kept turning around in passport
control he kept turning back and crying
and then he said his goodbyes it was
very strange and I thought we'll see
each other again soon in a few months
she did so this van against commercial
for a pillow when he kept kadarin image
bozena so busy no soft bite vida
busyness and pomona viviano wanted to
visit him in colombia where he worked as
a building surveyor for his brother's
company his children had stayed in
Berlin because Columbia was too
dangerous finally they planned a trip to
the country but for weeks they couldn't
reach one only his girlfriend
dr. Zee ma'am teen then she told me over
the phone that either something terrible
had happened or that he had gone I can't
remember the exact words in any case I
was shocked and asked what had happened
she said she couldn't talk on the phone
and hung up so and I went crazy I just
asked if he was dead she said no not
that 91 Pereira went missing on the way
to work he was presumed kidnapped by the
left-wing rebel group FARC according to
the missing persons report is happy
about Oz better than I called the
Foreign Office and bond there was a
whole department for abductions in South
America to add fuel and I asked what I
could do the man just said my father was
and always had been a Colombian citizen
that he'd never gained German
citizenship always Kangnam I told him I
was German I asked whether he could help
me but she was forced to try and find
her father on her own she even dealt
with the kidnappers an attempt of paying
the ransom failed FARC isn't the only
group to use kidnapping to fund their
operations the Marxist eln guerrillas
and criminal gangs also rely on ransom
money the conflict in Colombia started
in the 1960s 200,000 people have been
killed since then diesel estimate in and
shorten this is a list of abducted
people on the sand I wasn't even there
are one thousand seven abducted
Colombians on the list oh and then I
minus father my father's name is one of
the thousand year in the next to last
column
those 1007 people were kidnapped in just
one year the most famous victim of the
FARC rebels was the Colombian politician
ingrid betancourt she was abducted in
2002 and held captive in the jungle for
years in 2008 she was finally freed
after a rescue operation along with 14
other hostages at that moment Viviana's
hopes were raised Oh God can't a attaboy
sign could he be one of them could he be
free I stood in Tegel Airport in Berlin
staring at the screen and I broke into
tears I could see the other hostages as
well as ingrid betancourt and I thought
maybe he was one of them and I just
didn't recognize him because he'd
changed so much or he'd grown a beard or
lost weight or something and that's how
I had get some bad or that it's to Naga
Varden order yeah but that hope soon
vanished her father remained missing
Viviana wants to believe that he's alive
but now she's given his details to the
Red Cross for a different kind of search
today licinianus it in recent years in
Colombia they've taken on the task of
digging up mass graves and identifying
the bodies so I said if they can at
least find him in one of them even
though it sounds terrible at least we
would have some closure
the memory of Viviana's father lives on
she named her first daughter Juanita
after him
you
you